We also need to rescue the present for
the future and sure you'll recognize
Brewster Kahle--sorry, Brewster-- he's
sitting in the front seat another local
hero who who has an exemplary kind of
archive: The Internet Archive. Technology
allows people now to become their own
archivists what they're lacking is in
fact a robust backup system but because
of something like the Internet Archive
people are able to identify what is
valuable to them and uploaded onto
The Archive to be preserved.
I say coyly that people are able to do
this on institutions 'like' the Internet Archive, but I think many of us know that
the Internet Archive is unique and that
i think at least the real business of
libraries and archives is to replicate
something like the Internet Archive to
be able to make it possible to upload
people's memories as it were the things
that they value and preserve them for
the long term. We can talk more about
that at the break (or in Q&A). One last
thing i want to say about Thomas
Jefferson before I wind up is that one
of the things that's so instructive about
Jefferson's library is that he collected
everything that he thought it took to
create this new being the American
citizen. And he thought it was very
important to have everything about
America but also to have everything that
recorded all the virtues and all devices
men and his book is libraries were full
of books with written by people that he
strenuously disagreed with for example
Hume he couldn't stand Hume, the Tory, but
he kept that because he thought that
people needed to be able to know about
everything that humans thought and be
able to judge for themselves
we say to me the greatest threat to
memory going forward is that we would
create a "knowledge monoculture" in which all the stuff that we think is
correct that we agree with gets saved and
I think we're real hazard of doing this
everyone can say yes this would be true
of China or the Soviet Union when it gets
reincarnated in Russia that of course they want to
censor the past but I think we do it, too,
in our liberal democracy committed to
scientific knowledge trumping all other
kinds of knowledge that we always privilege some kind of knowledge
over others and i just want to point out
too that to the wonderful biological
truth that there is no such thing as a
fixed perfect being that a being is the
one that adjusts most rapidly to a
changing environment so that mammals
they didn't evolve legs so they could
walk on earth they actually had these
leg-like accoutrements these
kind of maladaptations that when
they were forced to to land on land they
could actually recruit to become legs
until they survive these are called
"exaptations" and I think that all the
superseded information that we have in
our libraries as these cultural
exaptations we all mourn the loss of
the Library of Alexandria but you know
it wasn't lost in war was lost it was
allowed to perish because first the
Christian emperors and later the Islamic
caliphate decided that it was full of
pagan learning which had no value for
the future and so they had no interest
in keeping it around but without the
recovery the excavation of that
knowledge during the Renaissance and
Reformation we would not have what we
have today we certainly wouldn't have
rediscovered the Greeks and the Romans
we wouldn't understand democracy and
we certainly wouldn't have the
foundations for scientific thinking
that we have. So I think our own kind of
temporal chauvinism poses a very great
risk for us right now. Our sort of
intellectual arrogance that because
we're were knowledgeable and scientific
about things that we actually know more
than those people in the past.
We don't.